sr stoffel musik
hören sie genau hin ja sie erkennt es
ist unsere nationalhymne und es sind
drei ganz wichtige worte in dieser hymne
einigkeit recht und freiheit genau diese
drei worte die fordern wir die fordert
bild ab 12 uhr 30 von den politikern
beim corona gipfel genau um dieses
papier hier geht es was erwarten wir
normalität erwarten wer was bekommen wir
stattdessen ist hier die rede von
weiteren einschränkungen ja und zu so
einem großen thema brauchen wir auch
einen großen man hier aus unserem haus
er besonders viel weiß und deshalb
freuen wir beide uns sehr dass unser
bild von zwei mal da ist ja schon guten
morgen so gross bin ich gerade groß im
sinne von du weißt hier alles und viel
und du weißt auch viel durch dieses
gerät das ist ganz wichtig warum ja ich
glaube ich habe so ein bisschen die avu
also in den vergangenen anderthalb
jahren glaube ich der pandemie da gab es
das hier ihr habt schon angesprochen das
papier und dann gab es das hier das
handy das iphone wo die informationen
zusammen kam
was in deutschland was bei den corona
maßnahmen passiert und natürlich werden
wir heute den ganzen tag uns auf dem
laufenden halten was um 12.30 dort
passiert man muss das einmal einordnen
das ist natürlich schon in wahrheit in
den vergangenen tagen losgegangen
gestern abend gab es das papier exklusiv
vermeldet von bild was dort drin steht
und ja was uns ein bisschen bisschen den
ja die die frage stellt was passiert
jetzt ja und die große frage warum sieht
das eigentlich alles immer noch genauso
aus wie in der situation als ist wenig
impfung oder keine impfung gab als die
inzidenz oben war man hat so ein
bisschen das gefühl man will trotzdem
weitermachen
vor allem ist es relativ dick um ehrlich
zu sein wieder mal eigentlich sollte es
ein bisschen schmaler sein wir gucken
mal zusammen auf das was da nämlich drin
steht zuerst schauen wir mal zum thema
masken massen pflicht ist ja eine so
eine debatte
und da heißt es um einen bestmöglichen
infektionsschutz zu gewährleisten gelten
weiterhin die basis schutzmasken für die
gesamte bevölkerung ja die
schutzmaßnahmen geben weiter ich denke
dass für viele menschen das problem
darin besteht das ist kein ende
sich das also die debatte um den
freiheitstag um den frieden
das was in england passiert das was in
dänemark auch ab dem ersten oktober
passiert das ist dort gar nicht
aufgeführt in dieser video
schaltkonferenz in dem entwurf der video
schaltkonferenz der bundeskanzlerin und
deswegen kann man sagen alles das was
bislang gegolten hat soll auch weiter
gelten und vor allem soll diese
epidemiologische schutzmaßnahme so nennt
man das im bundestag nach willen der
regierungschef einfach verlängert wird
also lange atem nur hinter der maske das
hast du sehr gut für sagt und langen
atem braucht man auch wenn es ums feiern
geht da sind wir ja leider irgendwie
schon gewohnt wir alle tun es gerne
dürfen es nicht mehr und es sieht auch
sehr sehr schlecht aus paul lasst uns in
den nächsten auszug schauen wie die
regierung sich zum thema feiern auf
äußert veranstaltungen feiert bars und
clubs sind die bereiche die mit einem
besonders hohen risiko für mehrfach
ansteckungen verbunden sind die länder
und kommunen werden weiterhin durch
einschränkende regelungen oder
situationsbezogene entscheidungen im
einzelfall die zulässige teilnehmerzahl
und den zugang begrenzen
wo dies erforderlich ist das ist jetzt
wieder ein anstrengendes deutsch aber
übersetzt übersetzt bedeutet und ich
keine partys in deutschland also keine
großen partys die wir in großbritannien
ja zum beispiel sehen oder auch in
anderen ländern wir erinnern uns auch in
israel als eine bestimmte zahl der
bevölkerung durch geimpft war sind die
klubs wieder komplett aufgegangen wir
haben hier in deutschland ein modell
gesehen dass man dass man versucht hat
in berlin aber sie haben doch dann
erhielt mit mit pcr test vorweg also da
wird man sich noch eine ganze weile
darauf einstellen dass das zumindest
nicht so frei wird wie es vorher war
kommen wir einmal auf die inzidenz auch
da war immer so das ding man hat sich
nur auf diese eine zahl eben verlassen
auf den incidents wert da ist man jetzt
ein bisschen von abgerückt wir schon
einmal in das dokument rein da heißt es
bund und länder werden alle indikatoren
insbesondere die inzidenz die impfquote
und die zahl der schweren
krankheitsverläufe sowie die
resultierende belastung des
gesundheitswesens genau beobachten und
sich auf weiteren maßnahmen verständigen
und so weiter und so fort
einmal paul
naja ich denke dass die inzidenz
weiterhin eine große rolle spielt und
das ist eigentlich die verwundung also
an 1 in dieser aufzählung steht die
inzidenz und da fragt man sich schon
wenn wir uns wieder der vergleich andere
länder anschauen die sind viel viel
höher wir sind bei der intelligenz und
um die 20 und in anderen ländern sind
wir bei 200 300 und das schert die gar
nicht mehr weil sie darauf gucken was
ist in den krankenhäusern los wie viel
ist die hospitalisierung rate wie viele
tote gibt es wirklich und da scheinen
sich zumindest diejenigen die weiterhin
auf der residenz beharren wollten die
gesundheitsministerien sparen aber dabei
auch die kanzlerin
insofern durchgesetzt haben dass das da
an der ersten stelle steht wo sich armin
laschet der nrw ministerpräsident und
kanzlerkandidat durchgesetzt hat das ist
bei der frage ob auch getestete künftig
zugang zu restaurants bekommen oder
nicht also die forderungen sozusagen der
zweig regel die auch von ihren sparen
und helge braun im kanzleramt
vielleicht auch noch mal kurz erklären
für alle die 2g 3g regel das sind gerade
so die worte die ende sachen pandemie
aufklappen also zweig wäre in dem fall
geimpft und genesen und bei 3g kommt
nochmal getestet hinzu das ist das was
wir bislang kennen und es gab forderung
im vorfeld der mpk im vorfeld der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dass
künftig nur noch zweig gelten sollte
aber das scheint für den moment
abgeräumt zu sein insbesondere nrw
ministerpräsident und kanzlerkandidat
der union armin laschet hatte sich dafür
eingesetzt dass auch getestete künftig
zugang in restaurants bekommen sollen
offenbar sollte da so ein bisschen der
versuch unternommen werden druck
auszuüben und zu sagen leute jetzt aber
unbedingt impfen bei sonst könnt ihr bei
am gesellschaftlichen leben nicht mehr
teilnehmen ich habe aus der konferenz
gehört oder von leuten die da im vorfeld
diskutiert haben dass es zum beispiel
auch überlegungen gab ob man das
testverfahren soweit umstellt dass
künftig nur noch pcr test also die test
die länger dauern
man kennt das in der der testweise
selbsttests das geht relativ schnell der
schnelltest oder der pcr test und das
nur noch der gelten sollte und das hätte
bedeutet dass es natürlich für menschen
viel viel schwieriger würde dann und
länger dauert für mich die impfte eine
möglichkeit für das restaurant oder den
theaterbesuch
und eure kostenintensiver denn so einen
pcr-test habe ich erst letztens gemacht
vor einer reise da zahlt man dann auch
locker und schnell seine 100 euro
absolut aber noch einmal das scheint für
den moment abgewendet zu sein man weiß
nie was ich heute ab 12.30 hier und
woanders ergeben wird wir sind bild und
wir liefern dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren